hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see
and in the previous videos you could see
us hooking up electricity getting water
planting a lot of herbs
and now this is all set up i realized we
actually achieved a very cool thing let
me show you
[Music]
okay so this is kind of a specialty um
and i think this tea gives us a lot of
hope let me explain so usually when i
got a tea
the tea would come from china
then electricity and water i have no
idea where it came from and in the end i
pee it and it goes to a sewage system
somewhere far away
but this tea is quite different because
the water comes from 10 meter away from
here and the electricity to heat it up
is generated on the solar on the roof
and the tea or the herbs itself they
grow right there in the garden
so to produce this tea it's all made
here and in the end when i'm done i pee
it back into the land so it's a very
small little circular system just to
make a tea which is a massive difference
compared to a usual tea
even though in the end they're both just
nice teas
but i think this tea is a good
representation of how we like to have
our little systems on the land here to
try to make them as local as possible
to reduce the amount of energy and
electricity and resources needed to
drink a tea and obviously this can apply
to many other things but the tea is a
good starting point so i'm quite excited
now drinking this tea
anyway this update is not about these
this update is actually going to be a
bit chaos because this week we had a lot
of people dropping by and not
necessarily long-term helpers but for
two weeks we're gonna have a lot of
people helping out from fresh plastic
because we had a little reunion to come
together and uh yeah when these people
come they also want to work and do stuff
so in this update i'm going to show you
a lot of little things we've been doing
this week it started by people dropping
by in our van and this is actually why
we cleaned the van area in update 14 so
people can just
park and sleep
and all the pathways we chopped in the
early updates were used so we can have a
tour at their land it's usually the
first thing we do with the visitors walk
the pathway so they can have a good
glimpse of the land
including climbing up some rocks to get
a good view
and the big rock actually turns out to
be a bit more complex for most people
but all good
but we did notice we actually missed the
pot to go straight from base camp to the
creek
where people can cool down when it's too
hot and take a little dip
so julian alex started chopping a pot
through the mimosa forest
it's kind of cool because it's an area
we actually never really explored until
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it turned out to be a beautiful pot and
they also found something great while
making it
here alex can show you so here we are at
the big grass patch over there is kind
of a campsite it's nice by the creek
it's when it's nice and hot
and usually to get to base camp from
here you'd have to go all the way around
through the grass field and then go up
it's kind of boring so we decided to
chop a new path and we found a new ruin
let's go check it out
so this part is like full of thorns
cleared it out mostly
and you can see here
a lot of burnt wood from the fire that
happened earlier on the land this used
to be a big oak tree that just burned in
the fire
it's kind of sad now it's just these
little mimosas everywhere there are all
sorts of scraps here from the fire this
looks like a wheel from a car maybe
right so here's the old washing machine
and the drum
you can even see the motor from where it
was before
and we're not really sure if it works
but these trees we decided to strip to
try to kill the roots and that way once
this tree dies more won't come back
because they they grow from the roots so
yeah
because it's uh invasive memories up
here
yeah
and we leveled some of the land here to
make it a bit nicer
[Applause]
and now the path goes up that way but
we're gonna go over there and check out
the ruin in that big oak tree
[Applause]
it's kind of steep
[Applause]
so
here we have the ruin
and this one isn't really modern like
the other ruins we found it's just big
granite stones
which keep it nice and cool and we're
not really sure what we'd use it for yet
but it's nice to find it because it's
really easy to legalize these structures
and then we can build here whatever we
want in the future
so i found a bit of a treasure yeah
it's kind of nice
is it fun to cut julie
it's all right
[Applause]
and it also became quite hot in these
recent days so we enforced our dam put a
few big stones that we found near the
kitchen and yeah just make the water
level go up
[Music]
also this guy had a genius idea uh so
today we're testing
portugal sun see if it's strong enough
for
uh for our needs so we're gonna try and
boil an egg on the container
and it's uh pretty hot we just uh give
it a quick wash now it's drying up all
the water and next we're gonna be
cooking up an egg in there frying an egg
and that will be fed to dave atkins
there so
let's see if he survives project camp
goes on otherwise sorry guys it's all
over yeah it's all over
yeah that look cooler in the videos
didn't really work
and a few weeks ago we also found this
big yellow cover we wanted to make a
shade roof with it for the workspace so
it's easier to work outside
so we set up a few old trees in the back
and front of the workspace and connected
the tarp
but the whole thing was catching wind
collecting water at night
so yeah before it would break something
we just took it down again so no shade
roof yet
and before we set up a shower to cool
down in the heat but this was quite
exposed i mean it's naked in the middle
of base camp so michael wanted to make a
wall
and we have many trees on our land but
they're still all very young max four
years old and kind of weak so it's hard
to really build things with and we've
been looking for applications and
something like a wall for a shower
actually seems like a good fit since it
doesn't have much structural strength to
it
so we started chopping
do
[Music]
do
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
and during this time we also had a lot
of meetings because most of us didn't
meet in the last one and a half year so
it was a good moment to align discuss
all our projects and plan ahead
so the week was kind of busy cooking in
bulk again okay so we are making chapati
one of the traditional
kenyan chapati techniques
we also had dutch television dropping by
and at night it got cozy in the vans
[Laughter]
[Music]
and some serious games got played
but for us here at project camp it was a
good moment to really test our systems
and we set up many things but do they
all work so for instance after two
cloudy days we were out of solar energy
the dishwashing system and ready yet
and some systems just broke
so yeah stuff to fix finally
and besides all of this we had some
friends visiting from tamira a community
in the south of portugal
we actually made a video about this
community before and for our research
which i'll put a link in the description
below
and these guys are called marcus hi and
silvano hi
they are specialists in permaculture and
water retention landscapes
they came to have a look at our lands
our plans and try to figure out what to
do next so we sat down with them to ask
a few questions to understand better the
upcoming challenges with the land
[Music]
the fire risk
in
this part of portugal
but in general and that we find a lot in
the iberian peninsula and many other
places in the world and here
it is
very much in people's minds which
creates a pressure and a fear
that more fires
might come in the near future
and and are in fact happening every
summer
and this land is surrounded by
eucalyptus plantation
which is prone to fire
and very hard to
extinguish
and
so there is a there is a factor of
unpredictable risk
that is coming with deciding to settle
and create a project particularly here
it is also a a challenge that we need to
face
on a global scale because
these
extremes that we are creating
through
the
destructive
industry and
exploitation of our ecosystems
we we need to turn that around by
regenerative
stewardship of land
so
it's also in a way the right choice to
to plant a seed of regeneration in
degraded areas like this one
[Music]
and there comes the topic of the
eucalyptus in
and also here you see in our back the
topic of the acacias the mimosas
and
usually the culture is of taking it out
taking it out of the land let it
disappear
um
but it can be also seen this problem or
this fear
as a gift and you can see it as a
huge source of organic matter that helps
you to create soil on the land which is
very much needed after many decades of
mismanagement of this land so
erosion happened the good soil went into
the valley and into the ocean
but we can reverse it and create soil
with the support of the acacia so
in this case we can
make more research
in finding the right methods of bringing
this organic matter directly onto the
soil so it can decompose
and create a sponge that can retain the
the rain and then refill the aquifers
and so springs pop up again and other
vegetation the native vegetation for
example can come up easier again
so
it's a challenge and it's great to have
them here now and to start to manage
them and to use them also and to replace
them
[Music]
i am thinking there is an inherent
challenge in
a movement from
urban
and urban lifestyle to a more rural area
and with that comes an unknown
unknown environment
for people who who decide to do that and
this is also a
it's something that is good to happen
and it needs to happen that
um
we we take
more and more people take land into
responsible stewardship and i personally
think um cities can be much less dense
densely populated and
there is a lot of land that
is calling for
a better stewardship by people and the
challenge in that is that many much of
the
practices and and the experiential
knowledge that
came from our from the people who
our ancestors people who have lived in
in more rural areas that knowledge is
lost so we need to
relearn a lot of that and
this
i think that with that come phases of
discomfort and and you feel a bit
inadequate
because
it's a different different way of life
[Music]
one of the good things is there is a lot
of water
so
usually if we think or people think
about portugal it's often
the topic wow it's very dry and there's
no water and
actually we have a lot of water and it's
enough for for many things we want to do
here on this land so
around thousand thousand two hundred
millimeters per year
is a lot of water it's it's more than in
berlin in london it's just about it's
all falling in wintertime
so
it's about management of this of this
amount of water
but it's a gift to have all this um on
this land falling down
so
and a gift is to have all this organic
matter just uh staining all over and
this in combination with the water that
we have from the sky this together
putting it on the ground it creates very
fast
soil
[Music]
another
aspect i would mention is that it is
with 10 hectares it offers
a beautiful
frame
to
to start working
with with that piece of land and as i
said earlier to take it into stewardship
learn about it and develop a
relationship it's not too big but it's
also not too small so i can see that
lots of eye
ideas and and
um
a decent group of of a decent amount of
people can live here there's
space and with that comes also certain
freedom
to
to do research and to
to create and to expand
[Music]
i wasn't so bothered by that
if if you would not have mentioned to me
i probably would not have noticed in
this short day here
and it's
weekend also same it didn't bother me
um
i'm
half italian so maybe i make myself very
much noise in my
daily
life so i also didn't hear it so much
but i think also it's uh
it wasn't the right time to
uh
have the experience of the noise
so it's also depending where you are i
was i had the privilege of
sleeping in the valley where it's more
protected
from uh
the
sound of the of the street
so i think it's also quite about where
to
place ourselves in
in where put the housings
where we are confronted within
the noise or not
[Music]
tool
i mean i
i saw already that you bought a chainsaw
and i saw already that you bought
like a brush cutter to put down all the
brumbles or to start to put down the
brumbles this is already really a good
approach that you don't have to do it by
hand anymore how you did it at the
beginning you see it in the youtube
videos
i would say
it would be a wood chipper
i had the same
like everything that brings down the
organic matter that make it small for
the earth using it as fast as possible
for the microorganism mushroom mycelia
and
warms and so on
this is
great so it's a time machine for the
future
so usually you guys are not really on
the youtube now you are you have any
message for the people on youtube
the earth is calling
for
partnership
for
i feel
in in our lifetime in this in this time
we
we witness how humanity is is
understanding that we're living on a
finite planet
more and more people i think
are
not only affected by it but are also
aware of it and
i if it's calling you follow the call go
establish your relationship with with
land the call for land is also a call
for
responsibility like we let's take
responsibility within the country within
the continent and and the closer
proximity of where we are
and so we
we can take out
can reduce our participation in the
extractive
global capitalism
and we're really grounded in the soils
right where our feet are
i
i want to see that in my lifetime that
many people do that
all right so that was it for this video
and i think next week because we're
gonna have this big group of people
which is very rare we have one task on
our to-do list which we never did it's
uh to clean the big workspace it just
always seems too big too ambitious for
two people
so i think next week we're gonna clean
that one up which should be exciting
anyway thanks for watching and if you
like what we do make sure to visit
support.projectcomp.com
and we'll see you in the next video